assalamualaikum greetings of peace now I
want you guys to imagine being locked up
unjustly and all the chips are stacked
against you and you're finally convicted
and given a life sentence and the judge
says the only way you're getting out the
only way is if you go ahead and find
this key which Heath has thrown he says
to emphasize this point somewhere in the
middle of the ocean that's our next
guest Sami Lika Albanian from New York
this individual he is someone worth
meeting and alhamdulillah I got to sit
with him talk with him inshallah we'll
bring him in the studio to go more in
depth but there was some parts of his
story that I just couldn't help but
bring to you so we're gonna go through
it together and derive some benefits are
you ready
let's meet Sami Lika
[Music]
Salam alaikum wa rahmatullahi Katherine
my name is sam alito I was born in 1955
in Macedonia users from Yugoslavia I
came to the United States when I was 111
and had to go and I lived in New York
City all my life until 1988 when I was
accused of a murder and mm I was
convicted of another second-degree
murder and
I was sentenced upstate New York or 22
lat
did you guys hear that 22 lot life life
in prison but hum did a lot at the end
he was exonerated exonerated meaning he
was clear of all charges but that
hamdullah
in 2001 July 19 2001 I was released for
prison and exonerated in 2002 and we
were going on a New Year's Eve me a
friend of mine and my girlfriend at the
time while we were I was in the backseat
and my friend was in the front seat and
this guy was a Muslim norrisville Muslim
and all of a sudden my friend asks em
are you Muslim the guy says
alhamdulillah yes and my friend says of
course me too I'm a Muslim so the guy
was very happy yeah
and update that so what you guys going
and he says they're going to celebrate
New Year's Eve and this is New Year's
Eve uh-huh
that's it's not a
and me it's not New Year's for us anyway
so the guy was kind of baffled he says
what he means that we using the New
Year's for the whole world I couldn't
not be for you
we celebrate the way but if not a New
Year's for us anyway we have a different
media that caught my attention a little
bit so so I act I have a question for
him and all of a sudden he has the
mirror and he for some reason it just
holds the mirror up and he turns up the
mirror
so this way we will not look at the back
cap
and that that kind of caught my
attention so I try to speak to him and
he kind of did not answer me directly
whenever we stopped at the destination
we were gone I just don't I want to have
a question for you I said sure I said we
do
please let me know what happened you
you kind of flip the mirror speaking it
sure says because we Muslims we did not
have eye contact with woman
I kind of I just wanted to make sure
that was the case because has grown up
in my country we are remember that men
and women who did not have our contact
and that kind of really really was a big
a I was impressed did you understand
what he was impressed about that the cab
driver he turned up his rear view mirror
so he wouldn't be staring at his wife
not any man any man can respect that
would you rather have men flaunting and
not letting loose from their eyes
penetrating all over your wife well
that's what Islam tries to prevent from
happening from a man lusting and wanting
another man's wife even in his mind
maybe he'll never even come to that but
even in his mind but it starts from
there and then even for himself because
then that ends up corrupting the heart
so now you can understand a little bit
in context I was impressed by his
devotion
so I says to him listen I really wanted
to speak to you more in detail it's a
short anytime I said would you please
come inside I have a drink with Justin
all they don't drink it's just I just
don't only one that's all right so then
do not even have the solar cold or
something says to me no I would not sit
in table where there's alcohol I says
listen
you know I know he Maps I know you know
whenever you know we have a wedding or
something they come to the table and
they sit with us
they don't drink but they sit with us
and they are much probably knowledge
about the new world is it whatever it is
he says we are forbidden to do that
because of tradition Wow some people
again that stuff is like through the
roof like crazy what do you mean you
don't want to come in for a drink
I'm buying so Sammy invites some hey
this guy's really got Sammy's attention
he really respects the principle that
the cab driver is on he's not he's
flicking the rearview mirror and I
didn't want to stare at his wife he's
talking about not going any parties you
know he's focused she's dedicated he
knows his life mission his life life's
mission and most of these things are
just distractions they taking you away
from the goal man
corrupting the heart corrupting the
individually he won't have no part net
Sammy respects that so Sam's like come
on man let's go and have a drink I want
to talk some more Sammy smart guy he
wants to benefit let me see what this
guy you know he's really something
unique he says no he don't
hey how many people you know look you're
buying I'm in no man and he said you
don't even have to drink come on in have
a seat with me he don't even want to go
into in the environment the club like
bar environment because we know what
happens in these places and the Muslim
won't have no part in it and then he
mentions you know some people with
bigger heads bigger beards you know some
Imams duh hey the religion is not based
off that man all right we have the last
of mr. problem and peace of blessings be
upon him because there's there's many we
see many cases you know it's sad to say
you got some of your mom smoking
indulging in certain things and then
that turns people off no we don't we
don't go ahead and judge the religion on
act on actions of human beings right we
don't do that human beings fall short
many of times so we judged a religion by
the verbatim word of God the Quran and
the example of the last and final
message your problem huh may peace and
blessings be upon him and the teacher is
the scholars who are following that
tradition of course we got a respect
and we gotta learn from them now let's
continue on because this is amazing
isn't it he says no I'm not going in but
if you want to talk we can talk just
outside the bar outside the club okay
let's do it respect and our religion
what not allowed but he says to me
loosen his the car
whenever you worked
poor man I can't come and meet you
whatever whatever you are but I will not
go anyplace where there is alcohol now
look at that look he didn't close the
door altogether this is very important
for the Dower
look he didn't just say ah stock federal
law this you know not on me this guy you
know scum of the earth and I I don't
want to you know give him he's not
worthy of my time no he said look I'll
meet with you we can connect but I'm not
just I'm not going in the bar I'm not
going in the club I'm not going in those
environments that's not good for me so
he's protecting himself keeping himself
his heart safe because again you know
what goes on in there man
man will lose his whole life his
religion everything you know just one
incident one nice look at something that
he shouldn't be looking at and then some
alcohol and next thing you know hey
maybe he's driving a car crash kills
several people take it to the extreme he
catched some venereal at some some STD
well he loses his marriage who knows man
hey all sorts of stuff and corruption
opens up so you can respect that
when he stands for certain morals values
and principles can't you a Sammi
definitely did and the door was open you
want to meet up let's go we can go in
and meet up somewhere else and so this
is one point an important point that we
can take from there let's continue on I
took the car
and for sure I wanted to pull him back
so I went inside the place
and I went inside the place we were a
lot of lot of us we had like a VIP
evening evening
this was a Manhattan
although some my friends some reason is
my friend one before me and and he won't
told them that he's engaged with this
guy Muslim guy like a joke and they're
all waiting on me and accepted me so now
I'm on a phone or something sir
some of them and I was very very very
and that's when I told
that person to meet meant a lot anything
to say about him I will stop anybody and
that's when the conversations down to
cell phone
we only kiddin
but you know we were just joking I said
just no joke on this and that was what
happened
solid guy look at that let's derive some
benefit from net you know Sammy himself
was a stand-up guy
many people they end up getting bullied
right you're investigating into the true
if you want to know the purpose of life
you know and you're so excited and you
bring this to somebody or they see it
with a certain person maybe a Muslim
with the Quran whatever it is and they
start bullying you you get bullied he
was he was he was getting teased
bantered right but he said hey cut it
out respect and they put that to rest he
was a man of courage many people they
find the truth over here and they are
scared to go there because the truth is
surrounded by obstacles you got to dig
whatever is worth anything remember this
anything worth anything you've got to
struggle for you got a dig huh all of
the gold and the pearls and the oils you
got to uncover much of the dirt that
surrounds it you got a dig you got a
struggle a same thing with this Deen
with this Islam you got a struggle and
God tests you he was testing him and
look at what happened let's continue on
and all of a sudden that evening I lost
the call
and two months later
a blue track meaning
I was found guilty of murder
and no sentence for life found guilty of
murder sentence for life remember he got
exonerated he was an innocent man
comprehending that put yourself in his
shoes whatever struggle to struggle
you're going through man 12 years the
man gave up his life
imagine that think about it let's
continue on I went in
first thing was that thing with yes it
was second day of Ramadan 1990
and
but for some reason I had a belly
yes
addition
for some reason I was lovely at ease but
I said something has got to be good I
thought the first thing I thought about
was Ramadan that maybe something could
be that is amazing in and of itself look
at that some people you come in
that's it life is gone life you're
separated from your family falsely in
prison and a lost sense of tranquility
look he's at ease like who was in the
fire Ibrahim alayhi Salam Abraham in the
fire and it was cool for him huh
look at that when you're on certain
grounds and principles it's Ramadan and
you can see as the story develops he
always had this disbelief right he had
his belief in guy he just
it wasn't nurtured he didn't have the
direction you follow me so let's
continue on
he was cool like Abraham in the fire
hamdulillah God means something for me I
went inside
and I wanted to go to the the is to the
cold for Ramadan the prisoners whoever
fast they can go to the gym it's called
a theater so we go to the theater
[Music]
the men of that those people are fasting
and I go inside and they my family I'm a
gift are comes they start breaking fast
and they ask me
breakfast I said wouldn't mean I'm
meeting he said to me are you mean I
said yes I'm not fasting it says I don't
I don't fast I don't know nothing about
this soul anyway make a long story short
he went and sat down you know after that
in the prayer we said not to eat or not
you know they
they read in the crown and it was just
better that's not the book
from one person to the next or when it
comes to me there won't happen to go why
so to me you know how to read with you
know we do not know how to read Arabic
so you know I said I'm not a but I don't
know how to read and I don't know
nothing about his down matter of fact I
have no idea nothing so I want one of
you guys to teach me but this guy was
I'm alright Kevon around nine years
understand and he says to me
sure I'm gonna be happy to teach I'm so
glad that you came and welcome please
them and me Charlotte that's what
happened
yeah some also is very important many
people they don't know and they pretend
to know they fake it and then they end
up not benefiting because if they would
have just been humble and said look I
don't know teach me I want to be a
student like Sammy he was hung humble he
said I don't know but I want to know big
difference between someone who doesn't
know Massa know and someone who thinks
they know but they don't know let's
continue on now there was another part
of your story I was really I mean
there's so much to talk about so much
wisdom to be derived but let's get into
the other part that was very interesting
now you're waiting I mean eventually he
got exonerated a great injustice was
done to him he got freed exonerated of
all charges but now before that happened
you're sitting in court you know
potentially getting a life sentence
which you ended up getting and then
there was a Jewish man who was facing
three years tell us what happened from
there this is on the beginning when I
was first arrested and indicted for the
murder this is the outset
when in
I'm going through their motions I will
do now I was remanded without bail they
will not get me there and all of a
sudden this Jewish man that I met
through the blue pants he was around 67
years old
at that time he told me a lot 67 years
old and he had a yarmulke on him a short
time and he said to me
I'm going home today Sammy please take
my phone number because I want to come
and visit whatever whatever you gonna be
I'm gonna come and visit you I will
visit you because I'm leaving today
I said listen that's fine so he gives me
his phone number and they call his name
and then he says then he leaves you
it reads me and he leaves what I figure
I figured he left all of us on maybe
half an hour later so somebody comes
addict back to their other hope at the
moment and he does not have a yarmulke
monoi mystery hazard understand and he
has no tie on and he has his shirt open
and he was very disappointed and
in Rosedale mechanical and says there is
no God that's when I that really really
bought it and I told them like walking
says come here I said can you say that
Oh God
something happened says I was I just I
think that judge gave judge gave me a
3-year sentence because of that there's
no gun I'm sorry I was in my mind for
few minutes so but I understand so this
was the thing that really really panel
touched me because this man comes in
religious man and all of a sudden
something happens small anything that is
no God that is very interesting so you
see the confidence of the man they had
he had befriended the Jewish guy and the
Jewish guy was going to visit him and
and he thought he's going home he
thought hey he was very confident I'm
going home he's going in front of the
judge and he feels like okay I'm gonna
get bail but again it's in God's hands
hey and at the end he ended up getting
three years now this is a very important
point a benefit when you get tested what
do you do do you give up then he all of
a sudden Sammy got very very mad he said
to the Jewish guy he said what because
you got three years there's no God huh
and we see this happening a lot my God
Almighty Allah protect us from that
through difficulty and ease may we
always stay steadfast through the
struggle and never give up our faith our
Eman our certainty and conviction -
Allah knows best it's not always hard
it's patience is a bitter pill to
swallow but how many of us after the
calamity everything is settled now we
can see it's look back and say wow man
now I can go ahead and see clearly that
was actually good for me but you trusted
in the law as he did well one person was
at the end giving up God giving up on a
law no no no I Sammy stood fast right he
stood fast and that's why he was at the
end victorious let's go
at the same time half an hour later I
was balding and I was remanded I was
nervous I was not supposed to get him
get no bail
so what happened is for some reason my
my judge wasn't there
so was a new judge his lady she was very
liberal we found out later on she comes
in I mean I go in front of her and she
says well my lawyer and the DA had some
kind of argument between them so she
she's residing on a bench and she says
what's going on and and the DA says wait
a minute there is no bail for this guy
this guy wants bail a judge I want to
hear the guest she says he says there's
nothing to hear the case you know this
guy's not gonna get no bail she said
don't tell me who's gonna get there here
who's not gonna get there I can I'll
give him bail if I want to give a bill
this my quarter so all of a sudden she
he said you can't do that because judge
you know the case here she says I'll
give them build matter of fact right now
I've given bail for a quarter of a
million $250,000 oh my god bill came out
did you understand what happened so
Sammy he's not supposed to get bail
there's no way in hell as they say he's
getting bail
the DA's letting this judge who was
filling in for the other judge and just
so nothing's by chance my friends so the
DA is like telling his attorney why are
you even trying why you know there's no
way he's gonna get bail but he ends up
getting bail he ends up getting the bail
a law made that situation look he's set
to help some relief during his bail
hearing so he was be able to be out be
with his family but how many times think
about that where you think that there is
no way in hell as they say that's the
slang the lingo there's no way Jose
however you want to call it and then
help from the Almighty comes from ways
that you couldn't even imagine but you
got to be connected to the Almighty you
got to be connected to all law yeah for
that help to come you got to beseech him
right and this was what Sammy was doing
this is a great benefit to the right he
was connected he was connected he was
making dua and look at how the help came
from again where losses from ways and
you just couldn't imagine amazing so
tell us now so Sammy what happens at the
end how does everything
closing or you're a free man right now
talking to me talking to us okay what
happened here I was
1999
I have a board movement from a federal
judge this judge was named
david trailer begins the 86 page
decision against me
and ethnic and on his ruling he says
there is no more availability I denied
all the probabilities on this case and I
closed the case and I
anyway however this was December I think
December the you know December of 1999
anyway so the second largest in the
world
McDermott will so some reason that
mistake this they said that I don't know
why the all the evidences all the
evidence is there that you're
independent man and but we cannot give
no heads in the court system anyway so
in 2001 my lawyer he for some reason he
kept to speak to one of his old friends
in one of these banquets that they had a
banquet and he told my lawyer for some
reason what's the matter Michael I see
you kinda down Michael said my voice
Michael someone he says you know I have
a problem he's bothering me in my case
because I have in case I have a man that
is innocent and for some reason you know
this school systems are really really
hard on this case and he says what's
going on let me know so he says you know
he says because I work for a certain
Southern District I am but it's a
certainty some whatever you have so
Michael sent some motions whatever and
then all of a sudden that he has a date
[Music]
this was January of 2001
within six months June 21 they had
opened the case to be argued in the
federal court my case the three-judge
panel Judge Sonia Sotomayor Judge Parker
and judge Jacobs and I wasn't there
because you know
and everybody else so in this court you
only to speak the Consul to only speak
for 10 minutes and after 10 minutes you
must rest so my lawyer goes and all
indicates to me six ten minutes and
another judge
and hits the bottom there's a clock
undetermined and his department says
continue and speaks about ten more
minutes than the other judge
dependencies those 10 more minutes so
and altogether
he got 30 more 30 minutes actual time to
log in my case then what happens is the
district attorney goes to argue against
me and the judges for some reason they
just nailed them they kind of told them
what the DA was thinking about this case
anyway so they adjourned for the day and
they said they will let us know maybe my
lawyer says in about a year we will know
something about this case
favorite flavor
July 12 2001
[Music]
I got over that
I came out July 19 mm I'm a zookeeper
faith in God and a law you came out
stronger than ever
lessons learned give us some of your
feelings now towards the end when you're
in a situation you can't see the wisdom
but now after how many years 12 years
what do you see now that it's think out
it's over give us the wisdom that you
gave it to derive from this I just want
to I just want to say this that while I
was in prison I told my family members
and others used to come and see me I
mean I would I would tell them that do
not worry about me because in fact I had
very grateful that lost Mahalo has put
me in this condition so this way maybe
this was the way for me to get guidance
and I used to tell
if I had 5,000 years to live outside the
way I was I would not want it I would
stay inside the prison and I would not
the way our worst before Stan I was very
grateful
and then I told you people thought that
after a while I will go back the way I
was a lot of people think that this is
probably just a phase but no I am matter
of fact
I never never have never lost faith and
humbly that by the grace of Allah
and I got inshallah I try to get better
every day as goes by but but for no
turns I would I would I would have paid
any amount of money I would never regret
the time they're spending president just
because what I got
even though he's falsely in prison in
jail he's grown he's become a better
version of himself and he doesn't want
to go back to who he was outside he'd
rather even though he's innocent he
would rather stay inside and he
calculated that this was actually a gift
a blessing this struggle that he was
going to actually pulled him out even
though he was innocent he was still not
living purpose as has been ordained by
the crater for us to live very important
point and he would rather stay in the
prison and go out to see the old version
of himself he's an updated new version
let's continue on what advice do you
have for those youth young adults teens
whatever the case and they they see the
Tony Montana's and the Good Fellas and
Albanian gangsters and all those out
there people who are chasing that
lifestyle what advice do you have for
them that is only a delusion that is not
a life that is a doom that is that is no
I don't I do not wish this on no human
being because life is short and life is
very precious
in order for you to feel like that it's
only a delusion of the Shaitaan Shaitaan
but however we all make mistakes but the
best one of us is those who will repent
come back to all us wife and family I
would not I would not have no way in the
world I would suggest to anybody but to
come to you Stan if you don't know
anything about his dad come to the
mosque meet somebody some one who knows
anything about Islam and stick to the
religion of Allah so Allah and not be
deluded and this is
I mean yes to ever you
words of wisdom from Sami Lika
letting you know because you got many
people who are out for the show looking
at the people on the big screens the
rappers the the musicians and the
gangsters and the glitz and what they
call is glory but it's a nightmare and
it's a facade it's a delusion and many
people get caught up with it and he's
giving you the advice stay away from it
and then he invites you to explore to
look into you know Islam look into it as
potentially we know it is from the
Creator but for you who doesn't know
potentially it's a way of life from the
Almighty and be like Sammy was where he
was courageous
he wasn't like going to be bullied away
from the truth he stood for certain
grounds certain moral so he stood for
certain ethical grounds he saw someone
that really impressed him and from there
that was a catalyst for him to move
forward to learning more to growing and
he didn't let his situation destroy him
he didn't 12 years of his life he came
out better a new version of himself who
testified that I don't want to go back
to who I was even though he went in an
innocent man he came out a reformed man
many people will go to jail but they
don't come on reform because there is no
there's no blueprint Islam gives the
blueprint makes you a better human being
a better father a better family man a
better citizen it has everything you
need to grow to become a better version
of yourself like Sammy did inshallah if
you'd like to hear more about Sammy's
story more in depth go ahead leave it in
the comments below and Charlotte we can
get him on the show and sit down and do
it more in-depth interview I think this
is for someone who's a filmmaker I mean
this is someone you know we meet a lot
of brothers who are into doing the
documentaries and that I'm telling you
this is your man right here this is our
only a few incidents from his journey
but imagine how much more wisdom and how
many more events from his story that we
can derive benefit from
and if you're struggling look at Sami
Lika you got air you're on the outside
you're able to enjoy life enjoy it right
enjoy of the enjoy it in the pleasure of
your Creator and I hope to see you soon
Sami Lika thank you very much guys peace
be with you so I'm like thank you so
much it was an honor meeting you
Giselle hi thank you so much where you
belong
you